mais avant un point sur cette affaire
plutôt dérangeante survenus à l'hôpital
saint vincent de paul à paris
d'après le ministère de la santé au
moins 350 foetus et corps d'enfants
mort-nés datant pour certains de
plusieurs années ont été découverts dans
la chambre mortuaire de l'établissement
il était conservé en dehors de toute
légalité
valérie war robin de boules la police
scientifique les hauts responsables de
la santé publique pour faire la lumière
sur l'horreur à l'hôpital saint vincent
de paul
c'est dans la chambre mortuaire qu'on
s'était découvert à l'occasion d'un
changement de personnel
351 foetus ou corps de bébé mort né
il était conservée dans du formol
emballés dans des sacs plastiques
étiqueté certains étaient là depuis 1985
je tiens à vous faire part de ma
profonde émotion et de mon indignation
face à une telle découverte
cette situation exige un devoir de
vérité
une situation totalement illégale en
effet lorsque les parents ne réclament
pas le corps d'un enfant mort né
l'hôpital doit procéder à l'incinération
sous 10 jours deux enquêtes judiciaire
et administrative devront déterminer
comment et pourquoi on en est arrivé là
recherche médicale sauvages traffic ou
simple négligence
mais en face mu qui n'est pas
suffisamment est pas clairement organisé
et c'est de l'ordre de lherm ans ceci
étant dit il faut savoir ce qu'il en est
réellement
au delà de ce sentiment que je vous
livre les services de l'assistance
publique ont commencé à établir un
registre précis de tous les corps les
lieux ont été sécurisés
d'autre part des missions d'inspection
ont été ordonnées dans tous les hôpitaux
de l'assistance publique disposant d'une
maternité et d'une chambre mortuaire